OFFENDING WASHINGTON:  WE
WILL TELL YOU ABOUT ALL OF
THAT IN JUST A MINUTE.
BUT, FIRST TONIGHT,
DEMOCRATS ARE HOLDING YET
ANOTHER PRIMARY DEBATE THIS
HOUR.
THIS ONE IN LAS VEGAS FOR
THE FIRST TIME FORMER MAYOR
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG WILL BE
STANDING ON THE STAGE.
HIS CAMPAIGN FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO TELL NBC NEWS
THAT HE WILL NOT BE PERCHED
ON A BOX THIS EVENING.
IT’S NOT CLEAR IF THEY WERE
BRAGGING ABOUT THAT OR NOT.
IN FACT, BLOOMBERG SHOULDN’T
BE ON THE STAGE AT ALL.
FOR A FULL YEAR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MAINTAINED
CLEAR RULES ABOUT WHO
QUALIFIED FOR THEIR DEBATES.
CANDIDATES NEEDED TO MEET A
POLLING THRESHOLD.
THEY ALSO NEEDED DONATIONS
FROM A LARGE POOL OF PEOPLE
AND THAT WAS ON PURPOSE.
THE POINT WAS TO ENSURE THAT
CANDIDATES HAD ACTUAL
GRASSROOTS SUPPORT AND
WEREN’T, SAY, USING THEIR
VAST PERSONAL FORTUNES TO
BUY NAME RECOGNITION WITH
SLICK TV ADS DURING JUDGE
JUDY AND RISE MECHANICALLY
IN THE POLLS.
THEY DIDN’T WANT THAT
CANDIDATES LIKE CORY BOOKER
AND JULIAN CASTRO COMPLAINED
BITTERLY ABOUT THESE RULES
AND ASKED FOR THEM TO BE
CHANGED.
THE DNC WOULDN’T BUDGE.
IT WOULDN’T BE FAIR TO MAKE
EXCEPTIONS, THEY SAID.
AND THEN MAYOR MIKE ARRIVED.
FIRST HE SENT A $300,000
BRIBE TO THE DNC LAST
NOVEMBER JUST TWO DAYS
BEFORE ENTERING THE RACE.
AND THEN HE SPRAYED CASH ON
EVERY LIVING DEMOCRAT
WILLING TO WORK FOR HIM AND
THERE WERE MANY.
BY THE END OF JANUARY THE
DNC HAD CHANGED ITS MIND ON
ALL OF THIS AND THEN IT
CHANGED THE RULES.
THE PARTY GOT RID OF THE
DONOR REQUIREMENT.
SUDDENLY, MAGICALLY THE
RICHEST MAN TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT QUALIFIED FOR THE
DEBATE.
IN OTHER WORDS, BLOOMBERG
BOUGHT HIS WAY IN.
THAT’S HIS PLAN TO WIN THE
NOMINATION.
ELECTION.
IN CASE YOU ARE WONDERING
WHETHER THERE IS A
CONNECTION BETWEEN WEALTH
AND POLITICAL POWER, MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG IS HERE TO CONFIRM
IT.
IN FACT, HE HAS DECIDED TO
PROVE TO ALL OF US THAT OUR
DEMOCRACY IS FAKE.
THAT A MAN WITH A BLANK
PERSONALITY AND NOT A SINGLE
POPULAR IDEA CAN BECOME
PRESIDENT ANYWAY.
TRULY ON THE STRENGTH OF
30-SECOND TV SPOTS THAT HE
HAS PAID FOR HIMSELF.
HERE’S ONE OF THE LATEST OF
THOSE.
>> THERE’S NOBODY THAT I
RESPECT FOR AND FELT MORE
RESPECTED BY.
>> MIKE BELIEVES EXCELLENCE
IS NOT DEFINED BY GENDER.
>> MIKE BUILDS A CULTURE
THAT ADVANCES WOMEN.
>> AS A FOSTER PARENT OF 20
KIDS, THERE ARE TIMES WHERE
YOU NEED FLEXIBILITY WITH
YOUR SCHEDULE AND MIKE WAS
ALWAYS SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
MIKE SUPPORTS WOMEN.
HE PROMOTES WOMEN AND HE
RESPECTS WOMEN.
>> Tucker: MIKE SUPPORTS
WOMEN.
MIKE RESPECTS WOMEN.
RIGHT.
IF YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT YOU
KNOW IT ISN’T TRUE,
OBVIOUSLY.
JUST ASK THE PREGNANT
EMPLOYEE BLOOMBERG ORDERED
TO GET AN ABORTION.
WHEN MIKE BLOOMBERG BECOMES
THE FEMINIST CANDIDATE YOU
WILL KNOW WE HAVE ENTERED A
WORLD OF PURE LYING.
THAT’S THE WORLD OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE.
BEFORE LONG BLOOMBERG WILL
BE ON STAGE WITH GLORIA
STEINEM OR SOME OTHER WAVE
OF FEMINISM.
SPENT ENTIRE LIME SHATTERING
THE GLASS SCBLEELINGS OR
TRANSRIGHTS OR ETCHING OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CARAVAN
COMING UP ON A $20 BILL.
OUT WITH JACKSON, IN WITH
THE SACRED UNDOCUMENTED OR
WHATEVER SEEMS TO WORK AT
THE MOMENT.
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
IT’S NOT PRETTY.
IT MAY DEGRADE OUR SYSTEM
BEYOND SAVING.
BUT IF IT STOPS BERNIE
SANDERS FROM WINNING, THE
DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT IS